I'm gonna get right to my first guest
cuz he's not only sitting here but he's
one of my favorite people he does this
show as a host on occasion and it's
awesome every single time he does it his
thirty four thirty Dion's double play
debuts tonight on the worldwide leader
in sports at 9:00 Eastern Time he is
primetime himself Deon so you do most
what's going on I know they're good and
you're great with the Mizzou I love when
you do the show but I love to do the
show I love that but I hate leaving well
then the good thing is we got a nice
chunk of time right now before I just
don't say chunk of change
come on it's it's terrestrial radio you
know the drill
so apartment satellite so let's let's
get into the fact that this is Atlanta
love it okay this city is so beautiful
man this city so dear to my heart it
because I chose it you know it was
different when I came out in the draft
because I had gone to a all-american
function here in Atlanta and when I got
to the city and went to the airport I
was like dang we did a little thing at
hospital I was like dang start going
around the city to dying and to do the
different things that we had I was like
oh my god I had truly never seen
african-american people in such roles
and positions and titles that I had
never seen in my life and it blew my
mind
you know city officials doctors lawyers
political figures it blew my mind so I
said that's why I want to go because I
knew to do that was I was not apologetic
was a brash I was gonna be me and I felt
like Atlanta would at least understand
me and I said I'm not going to you don't
grab me I'm gonna play baseball if you
do I'm not going there
I'm not going there and sure Atlanta was
number five pick I was so happy I in
order to do and and I also love the
story that you've told and if you
wouldn't mind telling the audience here
as well at the combine
when you would be pulled into rooms and
you didn't know which room you were
being pulled into by which yeah yeah I
was I was I was you know it come back in
not back in that day everybody was
reaching for it ages in the hotel yeah
everybody was everybody structure you
can't be in a hotel you can't be on the
premises then it was everything was wow
so I'm backing away from crowds and
people trying to grab me and I backed
into this room and the giants was there
and it was the Giants room and they had
people sitting down taking these tests
what do they call these things oh yeah
like the psychology just me the thing
was that thick man and I sat down and it
gave me this thing what is this it's
this testing you know we need you to
take it I said oh what picture do you
have it's like the tenth I'll be going
for let's just get into it here I mean
Belichick said he watched you run the 40
at the combine and that you ran it and
then ran into the tunnel and is it true
it's not true okay you did not run into
a waiting car and being taken oh that
story just grows it's not sure I did
everything that I was asked to do now I
didn't lift I ain't doing out of that
because Jerry Rice did his they had laid
across my arms you know I don't know
where that comes when you're watching
the defensive backs weight reps of 220
why well if that guy would've got one
more rep YouTube in there on that play
three cones really nothing so I didn't
do any of this stuff right yeah well it
all worked out yeah and now I have not
been in the new house yet you're a
beautiful man is your banner up there at
least where Dean at yourself that your
because you that was your house yeah the
previous one and it was a good house
yeah on the way to tore down it was a
good house that was your house alone so
I'd like to know if there's still some
form or fashion
yes whose hat you some son got to be
some kind of prime some blasphemy if it
isn't now this this thirty four thirty
tonight is just all good it is no it's
not good it's great it really is but you
know what I wanted rich it been calling
me for years to do thirty four thirty
I'm sure you know you go play it over
over you're gonna get that hanging that
from this so I want to really bless
people so I don't want to just do the
football one or just the baseball let's
do one that really talked about what
really transpired behind the curtain on
the two sports one day so that's how
this came about I didn't want to do the
Norma C thing let's do something because
that day troubled me to this day and
people still really don't know what
transpired behind the curtains and I
can't wait for everyone to see it and
I'm still puzzled like my contract is
over July the 31st I'm still here and
you made me out to be the bad guy
how does that happen and you made me to
be the villain that I was being selfish
in that's why I love social media today
athlete has his opportunity to
articulate himself could you imagine if
I would have been in the era yeah first
of all good goodness huh the father was
I would have had sliding mmm dionan Kim
Kardashian yeah your Instagram game is
pretty on but you know what my whole
social media attribute to rich cuz I
wouldn't do it because the contrary to
what you may think I'm very like you
know I'm priming it today because this
is called but normally I'm Dion enriched
knows that and and I'm really Rekluse
when it comes to certain things and he
talked me into the way he got me he said
you know what you have you sent out an
inspirational every morning as long as
I've known you imagine how many more
people you could reach if you did this
and that's what got me years ago he was
on my butt but going on so she gob and
men to make sure that it was your name a
true at Deion Sanders true you know got
to get that mmm-hmm but the fact that I
would teach you anything about branding
or
i tribute it to you use on my butt about
it well I mean so so that the one day
for those let's just delve into it a
little bit and I want to give the whole
store away cuz everybody needs to watch
tonight at 9:00 Eastern on ESPN the
34:30 the the day that we're talking
about is the helicopter to go from one
place to the other knows a jet little
chip okay the helicopter was to get to
the jet right okay like I've never said
to anybody a man I need a helicopter to
get down 85 to get to the game I never
said I don't know how the next thing you
know a helicopters on the practice bill
waiting for me cool good driving that
traffic you had no idea I had no idea
who provided it who paid for it I know I
didn't I don't I have no idea who
provided that on a daily basis out the
football practice but I know the two
sports on one day to even think about
that it wasn't that I wanted to play two
sports on one day it was that the fact
that I'm getting ready to send my
Vulcans my beloved Bal Kazan football is
my heart out there against Dan Marino
duper Clayton and then net more without
me in the secondary that's stupid and
it's it's to me that selfish and I have
a football contract and now I got the
Braves saying they mad at me and it's
it's it's it's it's October the contract
is long gone so I'm helping you and you
had attitude with me I didn't understand
that and it really it hurt me man it
hurt me because it was like you're doing
so much for somebody that don't even
respect you and they have no regard for
the other team that you're playing with
because they felt like oh this is our
moment forget them well we're trying to
get to the playoffs too and I have a
whole group of teammates over there that
love me just as much as you love me and
I got love for them so just not being
there for them while I'm sitting on the
bench for nine innings how do I explain
that and that was the dilemma and it was
tough and it got to a point where after
I played in Miami I really wanted to
just take the plane back to Atlanta they
may forget y'all but kids adults
whatever you start
you finish whatever you start you finish
and I had to finish plus your teammates
are there too
hey it's not like your teammates were
the ones who were right and I love them
right and Smoltz E&T Pete and Terry
Pendleton and all Glavine Avery all
those guys man it was my guys Dave
Jess's Gant limp dog Lemke I love those
guys tonight this way you never heard
nothing that transpired out of any my
teammates it was just management and it
bothered me it's the same thing by the
way for TV I just want to say that as
well I'm serious I mean I'll never
forget when you first arrived at the NFL
Network mm-hmm and I had never really
met you okay I covered you and I had
watched you one of the first things you
did and I'll say this marry you cheese
coming up in our number three it was me
you and mooch for all those years yeah
okay doing the highlights and mooch had
just come off the field as a coach okay
you had many years now of working at CBS
as well and obviously but many decades
of being prime and so we got on the set
and mooch was on the end you were in the
middle and I was on the left but and you
after we did one show where mooch was
trying to figure out how to get in on
our conversations or the highlights you
came off the set and you're like why am
I in the middle like if I'm on the black
guy no but you were in the middle he
wanted to beat you said put me on the
end through because Mariucci could just
if he's out there on the end of the set
he's gonna get lost
nobody's gonna hear from him maybe he's
not gonna be in the mix and I'm like
that is one of the most you know sharing
giving self-aware comments I've ever
seen from any analysts and that is
that's typical of you and I want that
sent to home that is typical to think
you well the thing that always
emphasized his team team I mean I
wouldn't be where I am today without a
team and that's on the field off the
field with the family with the kids I
mean you gotta have a team and I truly
believe in that in all aspects man Deion
Sanders here on the Rich Eisen show I
guess
let's get into this a little bit here
Super Bowl 53 how do you see it working
out the Brady front that's it right next
question I love Jerry golf man can you
imagine what this kid is dealing with
all week
he downplaying it he didn't in the
middle of the season he kind of slid
even had a rough time at at the last
game early on and now you got a deal
with Brady man you got to look over the
cross I feel it noted this guy ain't no
joke so they don't rush for 200 yards
and he doesn't throw for at least 200
yards which they've never done up on the
McVeigh 200 and 200 it's gonna be a
problem it's gonna be a problem and
throwing for 200 yards is really
simplistic but they're gonna have to
rush to keep Tom off that field because
Tom is going to work they're gonna score
against that defense
you don't think sue and Donnell could
provide the pressure ain't no answer for
Donald let's just get this straight
right Haney ain't a man built in America
two men get handled all right and Sue
decide that he wants to play in the
playoffs right but Brady hadn't been
sacked in the during playoffs man he's
getting rid of the ball I mean this dude
is unbelievable he's unbelievable it's
gonna be tough it's gonna be tough for
the Rams
so you think the Patriots when it's all
said and done no I don't think you know
yeah okay can you pick against Brady in
a one-game test in in in Bella - I know
but he's he and he has lost yeah he is
he's lost 3 times 1/5 thank you ok I
just wanted to sit all right before I
let you go you're speaking to Colin
Murray later today yes I okay it's just
to bring this off I'm gonna search his
heart okay I'm gonna search his heart
everybody's talking about what the kids
should do what he shouldn't do I've been
in that situation it's a little
different because Beau and I went in a
little different because we could do
both sports because of the position
bocas are short whenever you want give
him the ball he still ball I could fall
out of bed in cover to this day I could
got at least a quarter left
a quarterback he can't do that the game
does not allow him to miss half a season
it still be a quarter but how you gonna
lead you can lead nobody nobody wants to
see you and half the season you're not
there in the summer and the spring in
the fall you got to be there so it's
gonna be tough he really has to make a
decision but the decision really is not
for us it's his heart I think the kid
heart says football what advice would
you give him if it's football
no what advice would you give him as
he's making this decision in his mind
you know where is he
once he tells me of course he wants to
take then I could be the navigational
system but I can't navigate him unless
he puts a dress in there that was good
[Applause]
what are you doing I don't know if you
know but I have five kids and these
phone bills are crazy
I had to partner with somebody that
could consolidate this mess we can
handle this now try to get them to do it
for 21 and just give me the dollar
oh that's branding this branding yeah
but but they're doing a fantastic job
I'm happy to be partnered with them
because they're gonna help a lot of you
I know you running up a phone I could
tell you right now the way you look at
your social media guy right yeah you got
all of the apps and all the stuff yeah
that's what I'm talking about
you need meant what I do he's got a 32
fold I definitely need you two phones
mint mobile with prime 34 30 so good one
more thing I'm sorry I just did this and
I've never done this before because you
know like will it be transparent much
but the little letter to myself I got
players tribute right you got to read it
you got to read that I'm him and wish I
am like like I'm really I mean I'd
killed
thing I got dougie Nene that krippwall
doing I've did god I wrote that thing
you've got to read the letter to a
seven-year-old pram it's good at the
players Tribune talking yes it is good
and that's Europe and then you're on the
air after the game right yes which means
you're not on pregame pregame is you
stay and do postgame and I know you
ain't Stan yeah that's not a man I miss
you on TV what are you talking about
every day yeah but I'm talking about I
miss being with seven or eight just gone
you just dipped on me you live I did not
dip in the morning you also abandon the
Brotherhood
oh yeah the hair oh good I'm not looking
good up underneath right now so this
woman well we got before
Ernie joints one last thing you know who
I'm running against on Saturday right Oh
Usain Bolt Richard stop rich rich why
are you doing this to yourself
I'm emotional for run rich run he's
training though now yeah I told you at
Glaser's gym training a fella named Zack
Gates who has done great it was crap
were post post you can't do it input
okay there it is right there I'm boxing
I've never seen you saying boxer do none
of that stuff I'm getting in shape
goodness
I want to see you start Sonali they need
to see that that's what I was man I'm
getting involved in that I'm getting
started you're gonna be proud of me this
year
I'm proud of you every year I know that
but then I'm not you know it's gonna be
great but I want to hug you this year
really mean it it's gonna happen
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience